姐，
做为一个资深的懒人，
太明白这其中的道理了，
情绪价值得给到位呀，
婆婆公公你得夸他们呀，
为孩子的付出呀，
老公带孩子睡觉你得夸他呀，
我感觉啊，
一万个男人在里面也找不出一个就是能带孩子睡觉的爸爸，
你太伟大了，
一通情绪价值输出，
反正我就是懒，
我就是不干活，
但是我让你们干的高兴，
你明白吗？
你别什么事儿，
就是人家也干了活了，
完了之后也得不到你的夸奖，
也得不到你的精神上的认可和慰藉，
那就不行了。
懒人要有懒人的自我修养，
我今年35岁，
男方37岁，
我们是在二三年，
当时我30相岁，
男方35岁，
经家人介绍相亲认识的，
我是头婚，
男方是二婚离异。
据说他的前妻是一个很漂亮的公务员，
他们短婚未育，
离婚的原因是因为女方要求他家在那个房产上加名字，
他家不愿意，
所以就离了。
之后他又单身了五年，
和我认识，
我们一个月领的证，
我们两家相隔差不多4km。
分别说一下我们俩各自的情况，
我是独生女，
老家有一套房子，
我工作地在省会城市，
我在这个城市待了16年，
从上大学到毕业工作一直在这个城市，
家庭都没有负债，
年收入差不多是在25万左右，
工作比较清闲时上25的。
婚前我的状态就是比较自由潇洒，
也经常会出国旅行这样的我爸爸去世了，
妈妈。
啊，
有退休金不多，
但是足够他一个人用，
他的物质要求不算高，
家庭存款差不多100万，
男方的话是独生子，
就在老家城市，
他们家有别墅，
这个别墅是在男方的名下，
然后有一套商铺，
价值差不多是500，
在他父母名下，
年租金差不多12万，
然后父母的退休金后两口加起来差不多是一万五。
男方的年薪差不多是在5万，
但他工作很清闲，
就是下午他可以有时间去带娃。
我们的孩子是纯奶粉喂养的，
就是生出来之后一直都是孩子爸爸带睡的，
奶粉钱是我出，
其余的都是他出，
我在婆家就基本不花钱，
生活都是老人支出的。
二三年10月结的婚，
半年之后就20年，
差不多五月的时候开始直接检查身体，
走入了试管这个流程，
然后10月份怀上的，
今年7月底生的，
生了一个男孩儿，
当时在月子中心，
回家以后就一直都是男方爸爸带睡，
然后爷爷奶奶帮着带，
我自己是单独睡的，
因为我不愿意放弃我的工作，
所以我9月份出了月子就立马又返回我工作的这个省会城市，
这个省会城市和老家大概是坐动车4个小时，
然后就矛盾慢慢的就显现出来了，
9月中旬我工作结束又回到婆家的时候，
那天在动车上应该是不小心感染到了什么病毒，
就阳了，
然后就那一整周就身体很不好，
加上我才生完孩子才出月子，
我腰。
很悲痛的，
整个人也不舒服，
然后在婆家就起得晚了些，
没有带孩子那块儿，
传染给小孩儿，
然后我就明显感觉到就是婆家人给我使脸色，
就是冷言冷语的，
对我爱答不理的，
但是他们当时又没有明说，
我是后来才知道他们当时不满意了，
只有10月份的时候我们能发生争吵，
然后就说你不带孩子，
你可以扫地拖地，
我就觉得我很委屈，
才生完孩子，
然后生病还要去做家务，
我就很不愿意，
国庆的假期10多天，
上一周我身体逐步的恢复了，
也在参与带娃做家务，
但是我就感觉婆家，
尤其是男方，
还有婆婆就对我很不满意，
就不冷不热的，
但他们做的又不是那么明显，
这期间发生了一件事情，
有一天我们带小孩去游泳，
当时孩子爸爸去上班了，
然后游泳的阿姨就说孩子买一个包皮，
因为我不知道这个什么东西，
我就跟孩子爸爸说，
然后他问我，
你看一下那个东西好不好，
或者质量好的话就买，
因为我分不清楚就是他评判的质量好或者不好是什么样的，
我就说等下次你带他游泳的时候你来买吧，
然后他当时不高兴了，
他觉得我不愿意给孩子出钱，
但我其实并没有，
之后他就中午下班回来就后对我爱答不理的，
比如说平时遛娃什么的，
就他们两母子就有说有笑的，
就不理我，
这些都是我后来才知道的，
他们当时都不会明说。
系列的爆发是24号那天早上，
因为我要早起坐动车，
之前都是男方，
他会早起给我做一个早餐，
然后送我。
到车站，
但是那天前一天晚上，
他妈妈就说让我自己吵，
当时就不高兴了，
就带着我的小狗啊，
我背着我的包就回我自己家了，
我妈妈家就是这么些小事儿的，
我感觉啊，
你可以向张柏芝学习一下，
你看过她的综艺就会以知道了，
她以前参加过一个综艺，
就是去农村给别人当儿媳妇儿了，
她就是属于那种确实也不想干活，
也挺懒，
但是她嘴甜，
她婆婆早公公早来亲戚朋友了什么的，
让她去做饭，
婆婆公公让她去做饭，
她也答应，
反正我就是嘴甜，
我都答应等到亲戚朋友来了之后等着她做饭，
你知道她做什么吗？
方便面，
她给艺人端一杯方便面出来，
应给我看过，
你明白是什么意思吗？
你就得学一下张柏芝的这种心态，
你得说话，
嘴得甜呐，
老说，
姐作为一个资深的懒人，
太明白这其中的道理啊，
情绪价值得给到位啊，
来在公公，
你得夸他们呀，
为孩子的付出呀，
老公带孩子睡觉你得夸他呀，
我感觉啊，
1万个男的里面也找不出一个就是能带孩子睡觉的爸爸，
你太伟大了，
一通情绪价值输出，
反正我就是懒，
我就是不干活，
但是我让你们干的高兴，
你明白吗？
你别什么事儿就是，
可人家也干了活了，
完了之后也得不到你的夸奖，
也得不到你的精神上的认可和慰藉，
那就不行了。
懒人要有懒人的自我修养，
懒人的自我修养就是活我可以不干，
但嘴我得动，
你是非干。
之间，
确实家里面的，
哎呀，
吃喝拉撒的都是公公婆婆都出钱了，
你一分钱都不出啊，
你就夸他们呀，
大方呀，
你就夸你老公细心呀，
夸你老公带孩子带的好啊，
夸你老公是吧？
我就没见过哪个男的带孩子有我老公带的这么好，
天天夸，
朋友圈也夸啊，
亲戚朋友面前夸，
邻居面前夸，
夸他呀，
这日子就好过了。
老菲姐，
就是我是一个高敏感的，
这种性格也比较内好，
而且很记仇，
你那天晚上可以在我自己家，
然后男方和他妈妈就来我家找我，
我们就把话给此都说明了，
我也不愿意住在他们家，
我觉得那种客居感让我很不自在，
而且我确定很不喜欢和对方有这种亲密的接触，
那你孩子打算怎么着呢？
我就是没有想好，
就是客观的说，
条件的话，
肯定是他们家更好一些，
但是我们家我也养得起，
而且我妈妈说她也会支持我，
他帮我带我们家的存款，
包括我的收入，
还有房产也养得好，
他确定他们家是有钱又有爱的一家人，
孩子如果说留给爸爸，
爷爷奶奶也和爸爸也会把他带的很好。
我给你的这个意见的话，
如果现在没有出现大的矛盾，
没有出现原则性的错误，
我们还是要调整一下自己的状态试一把，
如果说你没有通过努力去调整一下自己的状态，
去试一下，
然后这个家就散了的话，
我感觉有点对不起孩子，
他才3个月，
这一把吧，
好不好？
你觉得也没必要，
走到那一步，
完全没有必要。
你之所以会敏感，
还是你没有把自己放在一个女主人的位置上，
一旦有一天你把自己放在一个女主人的位置上的话，
这一切都是我的资源，
这一切都是我能调动的人、
事、
物、
劳动力，
都是我能调动的资源。
好好试一下啊，
去试一下啊，
就是我可以懒，
我可以不干活，
但是我得动嘴，
他说如果你不干活的话，
让我出钱去保姆，
我就觉得有点无语，
我让我妈妈过来帮我干活，
我妈妈跟我还能形成统一战线，
我感觉感觉他们这一家人是集体捆绑在一起，
就我一个外人，
那我就请我妈妈过来帮我干活，
也可以替换一下带孩子，
好的好的好啊，
就这样啊，
那些人可给好，
嗯，
拜拜，
大家也别骂女方敏感什么的，
生完孩子那个阶段，
如果发现周围的其他人都拧成一股神了，
就是对我比较双标，
那容易放大，
这很正常，
因为生完孩子那个激素不由人控制的，
它很正常的，
希望大家能够多多理解。
我老记得有一个电视剧双面胶嘛，
丽娟儿生完孩子了之后，
然后婆婆叫了一个什么表姐，
她老公她们仨就拧成一股绳，
都不让丽娟碰孩子，
不让丽娟儿给孩子洗澡，
不让丽娟儿跟孩子睡，
不让丽娟儿，
你只有孩子饿了的时候才抱给丽娟儿去喂奶。
就看到的时候，
我的心都起来了，
谁能懂我那个点？
姐妹们，
我好不容易拼了命生出来的孩子，
你们还不让我抱，
还不让我看，
还不让我亲近，
只有喂奶的时候才拿过来给我喂奶，
喂完奶了之后又给孩子又抱走了，
然后你们三个人形成一个团伙，
就欺负我，
就对付我，
我当时看到那一幕的时候，
我真的的心就起来了，
刚刚有个人说那多轻松呀，
什么什么的，
哎呦，
心情不一样，
你生完孩子了之后，
你就想看着孩子再累交给谁你也不放心，
有没有同感？
我说的这个话题和刚才那个姐妹呢，
就是两码事儿，
我只是想到这个事儿了，
并不是说他俩的处境一样，
他俩有一个处境是一样的，
因为呃，
一个房间里面住着他们都是一伙的，
就你不是一伙儿的对不对？
那个处境是一样的啊，
我感觉有了孩子之后，
我真的对谁都不放心，
刚开始的时候，
谁看着孩子我都不如我看着孩子，
因为我责任心强，
我只相信我自己，
谁看着孩子我都不放心。
你知道我这个育儿嫂来我家，
我都是通过监控，
反复无数次的去查看监控，
我慢慢才对他放心了。
刚开始的时候觉得育儿嫂想带着孩子下楼下去转一转啊，
呼吸一下新鲜空气啊，
想什么晒晒太阳啊什么的，
我都担心她把我孩子拐跑了。
后来时间长了，
慢慢的才建立那样的信任感，
到亲天都，
此时此刻我跟你明说，
只有我家女儿嫂带孩子我是放心的，
他亲爹带我都不放心，
她亲爹带孩子的时候我都随时在监。
里面查他是不是在打电话，
是不是在查抖音，
是不是又没有看住孩子，
就那天他俩我对象和月儿嫂在那聊天，
孩子就差点摔了，
要不是我在监控看的话，
孩子就从那个婴儿车上就摔下来了。
龙飞姐怎么确定月儿嫂以后不会干坏事儿呢？
我感觉人和人是相互的，
首先我们对月儿嫂非常的尊敬，
我们家月儿嫂挟天子以令诸侯，
我是猪，
他爸是猴，
我俩可听话了，
在月儿嫂面前非常听话，
说让买什么就买什么，
说不让干什么就不让干什么，
说让天持这个就得添持这个，
我们非常尊重育儿嫂，
就是情绪上就是给到足够的尊重，
然后金钱上我们也相对来说的话也还是可以哈，
我感觉人都是相互的嘛，
我们家育儿嫂在我们家全是滔天，
都得听他的，
记得点赞关注哦。